yes we're finally getting more and more
confirmation that this year's apple
watch series 8 will have a model with a
flat sided design finally a redesign
after so many years having the same old
curved design so what i'm going to do in
this video is go through all of the
brand new leaks and rumors and go
through the story of how we thought
there's going to be a flat apple watch
with the series 7 but it didn't happen
but thankfully there are a lot of puzzle
pieces coming together right now that
are showing that we are likely to get
the flat design this year so let's get
right into it now first of all this new
leak that just came out this morning
comes from shrimp apple pro he's
actually the one that showed off the new
pill plus cutout design he was the first
one to talk about it way back in the
summer of 2020 and before even the
iphone 13 came out and now everyone
agrees with them including all the cats
now this morning he came out and said
guess what is going flat this year at
john prosser now as soon as i saw this i
knew exactly what he was talking about
almost a full year ago john prosser who
owns front page tech came out with
exclusive renders with a new flat sided
apple watch design that everybody
thought was coming for the series seven
and the even crazier thing is that mark
german who's the most reliable apple
analyst
actually came out with a report before
we saw the new apple watch series 7
saying that this year's design is all
about the new flatter display and edges
so yes mark german vouched for john
prosser's leak not only that
ming shakuo also said the same thing
right before the apple event that showed
off the new series 7 saying that apple
is repairing an iphone 12-esque look for
the watch with flat sides and squared
off edges exactly what john prosser
showed off in his renders but
unfortunately when the event finally
came around this is what apple gave us
both the case and the display of series
7 have softer more rounded corners
softer more rounded corners yes he just
said that nowhere near the new flat
design that we were expecting now
initially i thought everything went
catastrophically wrong and apple had to
switch up the design and come out with
that new series seven but i have changed
my theory and i now believe that apple
planned the flat design for last year's
series seven but they ended up holding
off for another year because in march of
last year mark german said that apple
was planning to launch a new rugged
apple watch model for extreme sports
however a little bit later he said that
the explorer edition was delayed and it
could arrive next year so apple
basically delayed their plans for the
explorer edition and i believe that's
exactly what we are getting this year
especially after a couple months back
john prosser was on a podcast with mac
rumors and he revealed some very very
interesting information as you can see
right here john prosser was showing off
this cad file that his source sent to
him and based on what he saw he assumed
that the one on the left is actually the
same old series six and the one on the
right was the flat sided series seven
but then he realized the entire time
that the one on the left was actually
the new more rounded series seven but he
didn't realize that until after the
event and the one on the right is most
likely destined to be within the series
eight lineup and this is exactly what he
admitted he expects this year's apple
watch to have a flat sided model but
jumping back to shrimp apple pro's
tweets from this morning he retweeted
his own tweet talking about what's going
flat this year and he did confirm with
this source that there is gonna be a
flat front glass display for the apple
watch and he says there's a high chance
that this is the front glass for the
apple watch series eight now he didn't
mention anything about the redesign with
the flat sides or anything but this does
confirm
that the display this time is going to
be flat which is a complete change from
the displays that we've always had on
the apple watch and i think this means
that we're likely to get that flat
design and he also added some more
information saying that it's getting
ready for mass production relatively
soon probably the same time as the front
glass of the iphone 14 lineup now this
is a huge deal for me because for the
last few months i've been just going
hard on this theory that there is going
to be a new flat sided apple watch
series 8 and i think that it's going to
be called the pro model because apple is
going to show it off as an even better
more expensive edition special edition
with flat sides and a flat display
because it is going to be more rugged
it's going to be harder to break the
glass because it's going to be receded
under the metal rim so it's basically
going to be more rugged and to show you
guys the proof for my theory on why
there could be the extra more expensive
pro model we actually have a really
awesome leak from ross young who says
that the series 8 lineup will be coming
in three different sizes which is crazy
back in october he tweeted this don't be
surprised if there are three sizes next
year in terms of the apple watch and he
even said would you like to see a bigger
display on series 8 on the apple watch
in
2022 now this basically confirms that
there is going to be an even larger
display than the one that we just got
with the series 7 which is 41
millimeters and 45 millimeters and to
make everything even better in december
mark german came out and confirmed that
there are now going to be three
different apple watch models selling
this year he said there's going to be a
new apple watch sc a rugged model for
sports and a regular series 8 apple
watch so that's three different apple
watches in the lineup and then a couple
days after that minchi quo who was also
a famous and reliable apple analyst said
the same thing three new apple watch
models coming in
2022 and in my opinion this basically
confirms that apple is now getting rid
of the old series 3 apple watch with the
old square display design so now they're
going to have three different display
sizes and as you can see right here
apple's clear made a render of the three
designs that we should be expecting he
shows off the series 4 display design
which was released in 2018 and that's
the same for the series 5 the series 6
and the apple watch se and then of
course we have the new series 7 with the
larger display size and then the series
8 with an even larger display size
however he does not show off the flat
sided design at all which i think it is
going to be getting and i think it's
going to be exclusive for the new rugged
or pro model while the regular series 8
will have the same display specs as the
series 7. and now on top of that shrimp
apple pro actually replied to a tweet
asking if the bezels are getting way
slimmer he says that the bezels are
staying the same size despite having a
flat display which i think is going to
be larger and now you might think that
it makes total sense for the bezel size
to be reduced if you're increasing the
display size but not always because when
the iphone 12 came out it had the same
6.1 inch display size
however it was actually smaller 15
smaller and that's because we went from
a rounded design to a flat sided design
so when you're cutting off those edges
you're actually squeezing in the chassis
around the same display size as you can
see right here check this out if we
compare it to iphone 11 iphone 12 is 11
thinner 15 percent smaller in volume and
16 percent lighter and now if you're
wondering why i think the new larger
display size leads to a more expensive
pro model well that's because when
you're talking about apple whenever they
have a larger display on a product it's
always more expensive than the smaller
display products so because of that back
in december i tweeted out this 2022
apple watch lineup in my opinion we have
the 40 to 44 millimeter apple watch se
with an unchanged display size and it's
probably going to come with upgraded
internals and specs based on the series
6 instead of the series 5 which the
current se is based on and it's going to
be between 250 to 280 dollars then we
have the 41 to 45 millimeter apple watch
series 8 which is basically the same as
the series 7 display size for 400
and then finally we have the brand new
larger display 42 to 46 millimeter
display size with the square edge design
and that's going to be the explorer
edition or the pro model for between 400
and 450
but honestly at this point i think apple
can charge even more especially if
they're gonna make it come standard with
titanium material instead of aluminum
they could even price it at five six
seven hundred dollars and the reason i'm
holding on to that pro title is because
apple once considered launching an apple
watch pro yes there was a time in 2015
when they actually had this image apple
watch pro they were gonna release it but
they decided to hold off and not release
the pro model so in my opinion i think
the time is now for apple to be able to
make extra revenue and raise the average
sales price for the apple watch lineup
with the new pro model and that could
allow them to put the best features and
newest features onto the pro model first
before bringing it down to the rest of
the apple watch lineup now in terms of
what else we should expect with the new
apple watch series 8 well according to
minchiko it could be getting a body
temperature sensor that didn't make it
to the series 7. it could also be
getting a new satellite connectivity
feature along with the new iphones as
well and it could also be getting a new
crash detection feature where if you get
into a car crash and you're unresponsive
it could automatically dial 911 for you
which is awesome and of course there's
probably going to be a bunch of other
specs upgrades and features as well but
i think the big deal is that there's
more confirmation from shrimp apple pro
that we're getting a new flat redesign
with a new flat display and that is
going to be a huge deal now if you
totally disagree with my thoughts on
this let me know down in the comment
section below definitely check out one
of those two videos right there and
click the circle above to subscribe for
more videos like this one thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]